some governments around the world are
making these giant underground bases
at the airport the Cheyenne Mountain up
there in Colorado just like where NORAD
is and everything there's like a
doomsday bunker yeah but yeah it's an
underground bunker that's as big as or
twice as big as the airport yeah and
they can hold like 4 000 people or
something like that this is the end of
civilization the government's thinking
about it because they're interested in
fighting Wars in underground cities if
there's an extinction level event
there's going to be violence followed
very quickly yeah yeah you would love a
series about this